good morning believe nation today's
message is always aspire to be loyal
over to you jason calacanis awake mode
in espresso TV go you know and so I look
back at the people in my life and I'm
just so blessed to have so many people
have been so loyal to me and taught me
so much and then also I've gotten to be
a loyal friend to them as well and
that's really like I think when you look
at your career always aspire I'm not
saying I have succeeded but always
aspire to be the best most loyal person
you can be to your friends and develop
those long-term meaningful relationships
it is the core of what's valuable in
life I'm huge on loyalty and in my in my
books is kind of no gray line you it's
black and white I mean there are a
hundred percent loyal to you and expect
that some people or don't trust you
though and so with my team I think a lot
of people are hesitant to give up access
and control and passwords and stuff and
for me i'll give that away almost freely
and expect loyalty in return and i think
it it gives people level of trust
when when you show that you trust them
they're likely to trust you and give you
more if you feel like you're holding
back then they're going to hold back to
but then you cross the line and you do
something that that destroys our trust
it's ovah so question that day is how
important is loyalty for you leave in
the comments below and we're going to
join in the discussion thank you guys so
much for watching continue to believe
and we'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another
you have it to the camera shot effects
this ray so keep me go